before we jump into the video about
chapter 304 and melly Otis's new power i
just want to let you guys know that you
can head over right now to anime upper
calm and purchase anime inspired
clothing including bestsellers like
Eskin or praise the sun meliodas filled
the wrath and the brand-new demon king
Mele Otis all hail the king
they're also designs inspired by other
anime like black clover and my hero
academia the designs are totally
original created by Pro manga artist
cooze almighty you can find his links in
the description definitely check them
out so be sure to take advantage of this
opportunity now I practically only wear
these anime shirts fans of the channel
can get special discounts just use the
discount code in the description thank
you for your support and queue that
intro
[Music]
what up guys seven at least since
chapter 304 is out and we got some very
cool information about the power Mellie
Otis is using to absolutely wreck the
demon king and I wanted to explore that
power in more detail in this video make
sure to LIKE and subscribe if you want
to see more seven deadly sins videos if
a few videos a week is not enough to
satisfy your seven deadly sins fix you
can follow us on Instagram for daily
seven deadly sins posts and
conversations just search for an
Instagram account at anime uproar we
have an awesome community over there and
it's been blowing up recently so I
strongly recommend you check it out and
of course as you should expect there
will be manga spoilers in this video
I'll be talking about the newest chapter
after all so you've been warned now
without further ado let's jump into this
Arthurian inspired world ever since
chapter 285 we've been aware that Mellie
Otis is more opie than we probably ever
thought he was especially back when he
was having trouble beating Gila in
Chapter 285 Mellie Otis took off the
demon King's entire arm the demon king
is shocked usually opponents like Hawkes
brother wild can't even penetrate the
top layer of his flesh and here Mellie
Otis's emotions are able to tear through
his Armour skin and bones like it was
nothing the demon king and supreme deity
were also represented as all-powerful
gods up to this point Milly Otis said
that he and Elizabeth were powerless to
do anything against their overwhelming
might in the past however Mellie Otis
isn't only able to escape from his
father he is able to take off his entire
arm like it was nothing and get him to
panic and scream after him not very
godlike behavior then ever since chapter
301 we've been seeing Mellie Otis had
the clear advantage against his father
as they're fighting within his body in
Chapter 302 we see him fighting with the
sword of darkness Mellie Otis has
usually used some sort of blade but here
he just seems to be shaping his darkness
into an extremely sharp blade this blade
of darkness is so sharp that it can cut
through with demon Kings helmet with
ease Mellie Otis is clearly winning it
is only after the demon king tries to
convince him that Elizabeth is dead
that Mellie Otis is clear advantage is
ever brought into question just as
Mellie Otis's emotions are in danger of
embracing despair and losing to the
demon king his friends show up and he is
re-energized now this is
power of friendship done right as
meliodas says their presence and wishes
gives him strength even if they can't
physically participate in the fight this
is when we first see tiny balls of
darkness that are able to easily
penetrate the demon king who is confused
about this new power now that brings us
to the newest chapter chapter 304 as
zelgius and bond are fighting the demon
king outside meli Otis is using these
balls of darkness to keep completely
overpowering the demon king you can make
them fly quickly around himself to
protect himself and then send them
flying at the demon king in a moment's
notice the King asks and what is that
darkness that is able to pierce through
the armor and body of the demon king and
we finally get a clear response King
picks up on it he says are those
compressed and concentrated balls of
Darkness they have an unfathomable
density and force behind them using my
condense power back from the druid Cave
of trials as a basis he came up with the
idea but the captain's magic power is
greatly increased so it should be far
beyond the level it was then it's really
cool that they brought back something
that happened as far back as chapter 134
in that chapter King takes the water out
of a stick using his disaster power he
condenses it to the point that it is a
strong or stronger than a bead of Steel
Meli otis is intrigued by the idea of
concentrating power down and tries it
himself
he succeeds but they're called away at
that point and that is the end of it and
now 170 chapters later this little
moment turns out to be extremely
relevant thanks the king Mele Otis has
developed a technique that he can use to
seemingly easily beat the demon king so
even though the friends can't help
physically it was actually king his
friend who helped me leotis developed
this new power in the first place it's
just that as King points out Mele Otis
is much stronger now and has refined the
power to a much higher degree keep in
mind he learned this ability before he
even got his full power restored which
brought him up to a base level of 32,500
which further increased after he was
revived and kept on increasing right up
until now when he first tried to
condense his power his base level
without a demon mark was only three
thousand three hundred and seventy so
you can imagine just how much stronger
this ability would be now
after all of his growth and after he's
awaken his original power what the demon
Kings seem to refer to as his inner
demon Lord power that seems to be so
great
he can't even last a day in the mortal
plane thus he's pretty much saying he's
unlocked a godly power and he's taken
this insane amount of power and
condensed it into tiny little balls that
he can use to block any attack and
simultaneously destroy whatever attacked
him the demon Kings sword that
previously stood up to the sword of
darkness is completely destroyed by Mele
Otis's condensed balls of darkness his
friends cheer him on and DeeAnn says
that the seven deadly sins dragon's sin
Mele Otis is the strongest finally we
get someone to confirm what we've been
thinking for so long that Mele Otis is
now the strongest Mele Otis tells him
that he'll finish up with a demon King
quickly that they should go on ahead and
he'll be right there as he continues to
attack him with his condensed magic it
is clear that the demon king doesn't
stand a chance at this point the demon
king seems utterly defeated as he coughs
up blood and Mele Otis promises to
finish the battle with the next attack
we are told that it is time to put an
end to the curse destiny suggesting that
Mele Otis will in fact be wrapping up
this one-on-one battle in the next
chapter
so that is Mele Otis's new power not
only is a godly amount of power that
does not even allow him to stay in the
mortal plane
he's even condensed it down to the point
that it can easily penetrate the demon
Kings armor and flesh I love the fact
that he used something he learned from
King way back 170 chapters ago now it
makes sense how Mele Otis was able to
keep overpowering the demon king who is
presented as a godly figure so easily he
matched it with godly power of his own
but condensed it to such a fine point
that it could even destroy a godly
opponent along with Mele Otis's new
power chapter 304 was crazy because of
zeldron this chapter was actually named
after him he is called the executioner
and this chapter was called the
executioner's request after stepping in
to help in the last chapter against the
demon king this chapter the demon king
took away his all juses resistance to
magic that he had given him previously
in this way he may
to injure him very seriously to the
point where some fans think he's dead
and the next chapter is called death
agony so it might be the case zel gist
is one of my favorite characters and I
definitely don't want to see him go we
see that after completely exhausting
himself and remember he's been fighting
a lot of hard consecutive battles and
receiving that serious injury from the
demon king zelgius finally leaves the
rest to his big brother Mele Otis saying
I know you will be able to change
everything as we know he wants Mele Otis
to become the demon king and save his
law of gelda who has been sealed away
with the other vampires he has faith in
his big brother and he believes that he
will pull through and fulfill his
request but Wow after all that effort
and non-stop fighting all I can say is
zelgius deserves to rest good night
sweet prince and that is it for today's
video I hope like me you enjoyed this
epic chapter let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and let
me know if you have any questions you
want me to address in future videos if
you liked this video make sure to smash
that like one to let me know if you
haven't make sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell for more seven
deadly sins videos and if you want to
continue the conversation right now head
over to instagram and follow our
instagram at anime out drawer for daily
seven deadly sins posts and I want to
give a big thank you to all of these
patrons over on patreon for supporting
our videos especially to our pro tier
patrons a17 FF DP keel on the one and
only Gilgamesh and our very first the
one tier patron the one who stands above
all Maddie Mac two three nine thank you
all so much if you want to support our
content you can go over on patreon and
support it for as little as one dollar a
month if you do you'll also be featured
in future videos among these amazing
people right here it'll be recorded
forever in history and you'll also get
access to our VIP patron only discord
where we've been talking a lot about
this
Deadly Sins lastly consider grabbing
your very own seven deadly sins inspired
merge at anime uproar calm link in
description we have shirts like Mele
Otisfield the wrath ESCA nor praise the
sun and demon king Mele Otis all hail
the king there's even a special discount
code that fans of the channel can use
I'll write that code in the description
thank you so much for all of your
support and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]